يبدو ان هناك خبر عاجلا عن الكرملين يقول
ان القوات الروسيه والاستخبارات
تعطل طائرتين مسيرتين رانيا
هاتين الطائرتان يبدو انه ما حاولت الهجوم
على الكرملين في موسكو
نعم بالفعل عثمان قبل لحظات اعلن الكريم
رسميا عن محاولات من قبل الجانب الاوكراني
لشن هجوم شن هجوم الليله الماضي على
الكرملين في هذا الاطار الكريملين اشار
الى ان هذه كانت محاوله
يعني استهداف الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين وصفت هذه العمليه
بالارهابيه واشار ايضا الكرملين الا ان
يعني الرئيس الروسي لم يتضرر جراء هذا
الحادث الذي استهدف مره اخرى ليله امس
في العاصمه موسكو طبعا هذا تطور في غايه
الاهميه عثمان نحن سمعنا في الاونه
الاخيره عن مسيرات تم العثور عليها على في
ضواحي موسكو في المناطق الحدوديه ولكن
عندما يدور الحديث عن هذا يعني استهداف
قلب العاصمه موسكو هذا كله يتزمر ايضا مع
ما سمعناه من احداث قبل قليل في شبه جزيره
القرم واعتقال عملاء
يقفوا ورائهم مسؤولون رفيعوا المستوى في
كييف كل هذا يعني حاليا ينم عن امكانيه
تطورات في غايه الاهميه تطورات ليس فقط
على الصعيد السياسي لكن على الصعيد
الميداني وعسكري السؤال حاليا عثمان
بالدراجه الاولى كيف سترد موسكو على
استهداف الكريبلين هذه تهديد مباشر
للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين وهذا ما اكد
عليه الكريم قبل لحظات في بيانه وعليه هل
روسيا ستستخدم كما هددت في مرات سابقه
كثيره كل امكاناتها العسكريه
الرد على صانعي القرار في كيف هل ستقوم
باستهداف العاصمه
مواقع صنع القرار ردا على هذه الخطوه وهذا
في حال تم بالفعل عثمان سيكون تطور في
غايه الاهميه في العمليه العسكريه بشكل
عام وما سيتم في المرحله المقبله لاسيما
فيما يتعلق بمصير الرئيس الاوكراني
والمقربين له في العاصمه التكيف هل
[تصفيق]